after four seasons someone new finally
took the big chair on succession with
all the Roy's striving worth it in the
end spoilers for the series finale of
succession are ahead
the characters in succession reach
Shakespearean Heights and their tragic
Quests for power within the Roy family
the three siblings from Logan Roy's
second marriage Kendall shiv and Roman
long for their father's approval as well
as control of his business Empire the El
destroyed sibling Conor is the Court
Jester of succession especially after he
decides he should run for president
despite possessing no knowledge of
politics or any real work experience
he's got no track record nothing to beat
me with I'm a Clean Skin the Roy's have
passionate love-hate family Dynamics and
would steamroll over one another if it
meant Logan's approval or a larger chunk
of the power pie the core characters are
rounded up by shiv's bumbling yet
conniving husband Tom wamscans and the
Roy's awkward second cousin Greg Hirsch
Logan's psychophantic colleagues general
counsel Jerry Chief Financial Officer
Carl and Chief Operating Officer Frank
switch allegiances more often than they
change clothes every character in the
way star royco hierarchy is endlessly
trying to grab power and each thinks
themselves worthy of becoming Logan's
Heir and fans who think the Roy's may
have some basis in reality are correct
Jesse Armstrong explained we thought of
famous media families like the hearsts
to modern day Sumner Redstone John
Malone Ralph Roberts of Comcast Rupert
Murdoch and Robert and Rebecca Mercer
who founded Breitbart lots of real-life
moguls in the penultimate episode of
Season 4 Kendall realizes his
sabotage-filled schemes against Gojo
owner Lucas Matson may not have as much
support from his younger siblings as he
imagined Matson is set to purchase the
entire Roy Empire but after Logan's
untimely death Kendall wants one last
run commanding his father's Legacy
betrayals and breakdowns abound and by
the beginning of the finale Roman has
retreated to the tropical sanctuary of
his mother lady Caroline Collingwood
after convening at lady Caroline's
vacation home Kendall shiv and Roman
share some momentary authentic
tenderness while discussing the
company's future they collectively
decide to block the Gojo deal and make
Kendall Logan's successor after Kendall
gets word from Greg that Matson has
decided not to make shiv his American
CEO Roman and shiv blend a disgusting
concoction a meal fit for a king that
they force Kendall to drink to anoint
him I can't drink anymore well then
don't wear your crown sir oh no no no no
no no
[Music]
the siblings then joined Connor and his
wife Willa at their father's Penthouse
apartment which was sold to Connor by
Logan's Widow Marsha together they
quietly and tearfully watch a video of
their dad then all hell breaks loose
once they enter the way star offices
Kendall lies to his siblings about his
involvement in the accidental death of
Dodds at the end of the first season and
also physically attacks Roman Kendall's
behavior is enough to switch shiv's
board vote in favor of Matson in the end
all of the Roy siblings lose as Tom is
named the new CEO of waystar royco
Roman Roy is crude mean dysfunctional
and hilarious he's also often the only
Roy to show genuine empathy for example
when Logan's Mistress Carrie comes to
collect her belongings after his death
even Greg treats her with callous
cruelty after Carrie drops her purse
it's only Roman who genuinely asks if
she's okay nevertheless when Logan
dangles the carrot of power in front of
his youngest son Roman begins to make
moves that shove his subtly empathetic
nature aside he backs the presidential
run of hard right presidential candidate
Jared Menken and when shiv pleads with
Roman to reconsider her younger brother
doubles down instead in the finale Roman
is not okay the whole world saw his
emotional breakdown at his father's
funeral and he got punched by an
election protester at his mom's house he
lets down his guard and authentically
bonds with shiv and Kendall then when
Kendall's lies blow up the sibling
Alliance Roman feels hurt and disgusted
when we last see Roman he's sitting
alone at a bar sipping a Martini in a
wordless moment of self collection a
smile briefly spreads across his face
Roman is unburdened the fight for the
throne is over and the looming shadow of
Logan is gone
Kendall Roy may be the most irredeemable
character on succession Jeremy Strong
portrays Kendall with nuanced complexity
and irreparable Brokenness after Logan
cruelly snatches the throne from him in
season one Kendall spends the rest of
succession either in the throes of
self-pitying Destruction desperately
trying to win his father's approval or
trying to thwart Logan's plans on
Election Day Kendall decides to support
Jared Menken though he doesn't agree
with his politics and a menkin
presidential win could put his daughter
Sophie In Harm's Way all he ends up
caring about is menken's later broken
promise to block the Gojo deal Kendall's
narcissism colors all of his choices but
this is the first time he seems willing
to put his kids in Jeopardy in the
finale Kendall lies to shiv and Roman
about his vulnerable season 3 confession
and solidifies his self-serving
motivations and then pleads with shiv to
vote in his favor if I don't get to do
this
I I feel like
that's it like I might
like I might die he also hilariously and
childishly declares that he's the eldest
boy even though he isn't and
instantaneously erases any small
character growth he's experienced over
the course of the series in an exclusive
interview with Vanity Fair Jeremy Strong
said about his character it's a disaster
in slow motion for him and is
excruciating for me to see it all unfold
the way that it does
Siobhan shivroy has spent each season of
succession wading through a sea of
misogyny and trying not to drown as a
former political consultant she's the
only Roy with a proven professional
track record yet her ideas are shot down
and she's Betrayed at almost every turn
even with all that working against her
shiv still keeps herself in an important
position throughout the show Sarah snook
spoke to The Hollywood Reporter about
the motivations of her character and
said I think shiv is only really ever
going to align herself where the truest
amount of power is and the series finale
shiv and Roman finally admit to each
other that Logan probably didn't want
any of them to inherit his legacy yet
shiv still promises Kendall she'll back
his bid for the company but by the
episode's end she recognizes that even
if Kendall's plan succeeds she can't let
him run things he's a terrible person
and thus she changes her vote when Tom
earlier confesses that Matson has named
him waystar CEO shiv knows he didn't
stand up for her but he's still her best
shot at any semblance of power in her
last scene shiv reticently placed is her
hand on her husbands at least she'll
have power by proxy
though only in the family by marriage
Tom womsgams is just as conniving and
Cutthroat as the other Roy's his
bumbling veneer masks his aptitude to
play the power game Matthew McFadden
portrays Tom with such authenticity and
so many subtle layers the character
comes across as genuinely ineffectual
and spineless throughout season 4 Tom
worries that if Matson takes over the
company his head will be on the chopping
block he tries to angle back into shiv's
good graces and win matson's approval
too Tom breaks bread with Matson on the
night before the final vote on the way
star royco acquisition when making his
case to keep his job Tom tells Matson
his position entails cutting heads and
harvesting eyeballs I think I think of
all these blobs of jelly rolling around
in your head surprisingly Matson offers
him the CEO gig he says that he needs a
pain sponge and Tom's his guy years of
abuse from the Roy's the ability to
double cross anyone and an unassuming
public Persona make Tom the ideal
candidate mcfadian told The Hollywood
Reporter of saying goodbye to the
character it was sort of awful but I
will say that I think it's a good ending
I think it works
at the beginning of season 4 Greg and
Tom come up with the terrible nickname
the disgusting Brothers they're looking
to portray themselves as lotharios and
change the personas they give off
Nicholas Braun who plays Greg joked with
TV Insider about the nickname it's Greg
Tom disgusting maybe as men maybe not so
much physically it's more the concept of
them being disgusting in some ways the
name epitomizes the awkward Duo both
will grovel to no end to climb the
ladder of wealth and power cousin Greg
is Tom's Protege and when he commits any
dastardly deed his mentor beams with
pride by the finale it seems Greg's
friendship with Tom may be in Peril Greg
shares matson's plan to skip over shiv
as his American CEO with Kendall and Tom
is not happy at Logan's apartment Tom
confronts his Lackey and the two come to
feeble blows but after the board vote
Tom tells Greg he still has a place in
the company the truest friendship in
succession continues I got just enough
cap
I got you
poor Connor Roy is never taken seriously
as the only child from Logan Roy's first
marriage and the true eldest boy Connor
doesn't quite fit in with his siblings
he reaps the financial Bounty of waystar
royco but otherwise remains uninvolved
with its operations when he suddenly
chooses to throw his hat in the
presidential ring everyone thinks he's a
joke after Jared Menken becomes the
obvious GOP front-runner Connor is
offered an ambassadorship in exchange
for dropping out of the race I guess
you're gonna have to find some other
poor moocs perhaps to suckle on but he
doesn't do so immediately so the
ambassadorship he's offered is in
Slovenia in an interview with Vanity
Fair Alan Ruck imagined that should his
character receive the position he'll
definitely have buyer's remorse Connor
still assumes he's going to Slovenia as
a U.S ambassador even though Menken
didn't save the Roy's family run
operations and has never really had a
relationship with Conor even so Connor
and his much younger wife Willa are
already making enthusiastic plans for
their long-distance relationship
whatever happens there may be heartache
ahead for Connor Roy
Logan's Old School Executives are
sycophantic Hangers On and they've
managed to survive decades under his
rule yes Frank and Jerry were both fired
and rehired but neither has ever strayed
very far from the Roys after Logan's
death Jerry Frank and Carl are still an
integral part of the company's decisions
there's also Hugo waystar royco's senior
vice president of communications for
parks and cruises who has aligned
himself with Kendall it's pretty clear
Tom plans to cut him loose and Matson
has already put Frank and Carl on his
kill list Fisher Stevens said he thinks
Hugo will turn out fine though and told
The Hollywood Reporter Hugo's got a plan
I can't tell you the plan because I
don't want to give it away but I think
he's going to succeed happy
chances are Jerry Frank and Carl will
find a way to survive too Peter Friedman
who plays Frank told the guardian Frank
might be a good person so why is he with
these sharks why doesn't he join a
non-profit and spread good if he's so
damn moral
perhaps for the first time in their
lives the Roy siblings no longer have
the enormous pressure of succession
pinning them down at least temporarily
each will have to confront who they are
in the aftermath and grieve their losses
both of their father and of their power
under Tom's leadership oyster royko's
future is also uncertain Tom may have
prematurely called the presidential
election which will certainly change the
landscape at the news network ATN for
fans the ending means saying goodbye to
a phenomenally written intriguing drama
many have taken to social media to
express their feelings about the end of
an era one Twitter user summed it up
nicely tweeting Roman finally free from
the life he was living to please his dad
shiv holding on to Tom and therefore
some power meanwhile Kendall was left
with nothing I got it I got it I got it
the cast and Crews feelings about the
finale are just as Bittersweet as fans
it seems succession Creator Jesse
Armstrong told decider I think we all
feel really satisfied with the shape of
the season so sad but I think it's the
right thing to do Sarah snook shared
with the Los Angeles Times that the cast
didn't know that season 4 was to be the
last until they sat down for the table
read and she said that the discovery
made her feel a huge sense of loss
disappointment and sadness Jeremy Strong
spoke with GQ before the final episode
aired and disclosed that saying goodbye
to Kendall would feel like a death in a
way it's clear that succession had a
profound impact on the cast and crew who
brought the show's stories to life
the end of succession left some
unanswered questions the characters are
richly drawn and could provide endless
compelling stories in the future but
there are no immediate plans for a
succession spin-off the head of drama at
HBO Francesca orsi told deadline I'll
Never Say Never but my instinct and
based on a number of conversations about
the evolution of succession and these
characters at this stage there is no
intention of spinning any one character
off any further stories in the
succession Universe would also likely
require the participation of series
Creator Jesse Armstrong members of the
cast have fantasized about future
projects though Nicholas Braun imagined
a disgusting brother's spin-off in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
joking we go off to Antarctica and it's
just the two of us trying to survive and
then we die pretty quickly we die after
three or four episodes any number of
characters could sustain another series
Roman could look for love Kendall could
try to start a new company or what about
a prequel series about Logan for now
though we'll have to remain content with
the 40 episodes HBO has produced which
have allowed a glimpse of the brilliant
dysfunction of the Roy family Empire
foreign